foreign
I'm streaming
[Music]
oh
all right here we go
you guys should be able to hear me fine
so
[Music]
let me go ahead and switch the thing
the thing
[Music]
unfortunately my room is a mess right
now because I'm watching my girlfriends
kid or daughter
all right there we go
[Music]
so I'm waiting for it to install still
hold up
and I just ate two so I'm sure
so I got something called gerg
and it really affects me from from
eating
my camera is the way it is on purpose us
people are uh commenting on my camera
because I got people on this side of the
room
so in order to accommodate them
hold on give me one second guys I need a
take a tum or something
people
oh
that was rough
detention
[Music]
there we go
foreign
how's that look guys
how does that look chat
someone tell me how that looks
does it look good
that looks smexy
is that is that a word
is smexy a word
you should tell me
it looks terrible
it looks terrible what
cow man
cow why why are you
foreign
[Music]
the headset was on my head and I was
looking around this place for it and it
was on my head this whole time
uh
there we go
ah
I don't like how so much of
hold up
I gotta fix stuff a little bit real
quick I gotta go down a little bit
let's have a little bit above me
and then this gotta go down two with a
there we go
how long has it been downloading for a
minute for like two hours it's been
downloading for a minute
I mean see here's the thing I could go
into the game but I don't want it I
don't want it to take longer so we go
sit here and chat
thank you
this game is 96 gigs long big
96 gigs 96
hold on
[Music]
hmm
yeah yeah I have it plugged in it should
be it should be decently charged by now
but I do have it plugged in
yeah I'm downloading you dude because it
it just
poorly optimized or compressed or
whatever
it is it's poorly something I know that
for a fact it's poorly something
I got someone in the chat he's scared to
say anything
don't think I don't know that you scared
I see you texting me you and that chat
scared to say anything public you don't
want no one knowing that's that uh
that you in this chat isn't it isn't it
I'm not torture I like games dude I love
games and you know I'm willing to give
this game
a fair shot and I'm I really am going
into this legitly prepared to give it a
fair shot
um
they're not like the greatest but
[Music]
I got 12 minutes left
I have done the majority of the game
just gotta let it go man
someone shook yeah someone in my someone
someone
texted me man you know I'm not gonna
I'm not gonna show you
the no the name
but someone's definitely texting me
and they don't want to know
that they're in my chat
you know we won't say who it is
no snitching nah I would never do that
if someone if someone
I like my lurkers man my lurkers is
what's up
I would never make lurkers feel
uncomfortable being my chat
foreign
a little bit on the Abomination stuff
okay
I get it
I don't I'm streaming
uh I get it it's easy to make fun of a
game and I'm not even saying this game
isn't an Abomination I would probably
never use those words myself you know
I've
when you talk to actual devs and stuff
you realize that you know even though
that I don't like a game
sometimes your friends making it or
something and you know it hits a little
bit different you know I still give my
opinion on the matter I just don't use
like very crazy terms for it anymore if
that makes sense
[Music]
uh
-huh
there we go
no I haven't seen anyone's review yet
I could use more extreme turns than
abomination
I feel you
we about to find out ourselves though
I can but you got to stay on that side
what
oh
trash spoken you guys are ridiculous
you're ridiculous you know people do
want to act like Place Microsoft is the
only people that deliver you know kind
of a modern
sensation in in terms of the the kind of
content they have
people do I try to act like Microsoft's
the only people that do that when that's
that's not the case
yeah which is funny is high in life to a
lot of people you would consider that
definitely a better game
I think that would
be a fair assessment
that you consider that a better game
we got six minutes fellas six minutes I
repeat six minutes
you guys got
I'm trying to figure out a little bit
because I want to stream more but I got
to figure out a good way for me to
stream
[Music]
why isn't like
no way what
I see you Jose
what is it a no way of
720P
I'd rather play it at 720P
don't worry this chat used to waiting
hey a mask produce
don't be saying that now I don't know if
you coming at IOP saying that you guys
wait around for us like in the chat or
stuff are you saying we have an Xbox
audience and
and the audience is used to waiting I'm
kind of curious on which one you mean
I'm not playing at 30. I will play 720p
before I play 30.
it's not happening
you guys are bugging
how much needs to actually be downloaded
we got
a little bit less than three gigs
what's an Xbox
you guys are ridiculous
oh
there we go
I don't know yet I'm waiting for right
now I will Nina I'm waiting for it we
got a couple minutes left
and then we golden we good
can you guys hear this TV right here
tell me if you can hear the TV I'm right
in front of the mic so I don't think you
should be able to hear
but tell me if you can hear the TV
[Music]
yeah yeah
all right we're gonna fix it right now
[Music]
it's not
all right what about now
what you doing
hmm
like one
of them no
good morning
no it's not morning
you want some cotton candy
I'll give you some cotton candy since
you ate dinner
it's cold out there yeah
you can hear the game audio I was really
talking about the the TV behind me
making sure that you guys couldn't hear
that
oh
60.
60 seconds chat we're at it man 60
seconds 59 seconds 58 seconds 57 seconds
56 seconds 55 seconds 54 seconds 53
seconds 52 seconds 51 seconds 49 48 47
46 45 44 43 42 41 40 39 38 37 36 35
34 33 32 30 we have 30 seconds till we
experience
forsaken or forespoken or however do you
want to pronounce it
ten nine eight
seven six
three two one
[Music]
for spoken is downloaded
it's wicked cold outside yeah
might be my stepdaughter one day guys
might be my stepdaughter one day we'll
see we'll see
let me disable all the stuff at the top
okay
dad it could have been the knee that's
funny
[Music]
man this is a weird what happened to
just normal
hard and very hard or easy normal and
hard like why we got all this extra
stuff right now focus on the story
explore the open world take part in
challenging battles what happened with
just easy normal
and hard I'm kind of curious on that
[Music]
foreign
okay we'll explore
performance focused
so far
everyone has something they're willing
to fight for
could be family
friends
your beliefs
your home
no matter who you are there's just some
things you have to protect
but what do you do when the world fights
back
guess I know now Tower to get you a hey
Patty here Rice Krispie treats and send
her back in here
but I was not ready to hear it
honorable Judge my bird presiding in the
case of people the state of New York
versus Alfred home
defendant charge would attempt to grand
larceny
Heidi plead not guilty your honor
I see
officer please remove her cuffs
now before we begin
perhaps you should reacquaint yourself
with your many previous encounters with
the law
oh read the document on the left read it
in the middle read on the right
huh
uh we'll go left it looks like a high
school diploma of some sort
haven't seen this in a while
let's read the one in the middle
[Music]
so her
her note Alias is is free she's been
charged with grand lar sitting and
resisting arrest
I wish I could have read that they
didn't really give me a lot of
opportunities to read that
why are you here free grand larceny is
that who you really are
no it's just I needed the cash for
never mind
sooner or later you're going to have to
start taking accountability for your
actions
are you familiar with the persistent
felony offender law also known as the
three strikes law wait you can't do that
I never hurt anyone just yourself you
have two previous felony thefts and with
this new one your grand total will be
three
this could put you away for a very very
long time you have so much potential
I can do so much more with my life I I'm
a smart girl with a bright future I was
going to say you have so much anger and
resentment in you I'm not sure you'll
ever amount to anything at all
truth hurts
but
in the holiday spirit in the holidays
I'm going to give you an early presence
I'm going to release you under the
condition you serve 120 hours of
community service
thanks
regret it
next time you end up in front of me I
will not be as lenient we clear
good
you're free to go she lives in the good
part of Manhattan uh cocktail took me to
Manhattan you know it's definitely a
nice area it's like a lot of tall
buildings
pray
one more thing
happy almost birthday
seems like it's not too late to start
using your gifts to help others
[Music]
yeah we got a review code you know kind
of late
which is not really their fault because
I didn't miss close really request one
either just saved my ass
won't get that lucky again
thank you so much no worries happens to
all of us you save my life seriously
happy holidays
um happy holidays
is this a world game I don't know yet
Thomas
we have no idea
I should get back to Homer poor girl
needs her dinner
phrase Journey just another day
let me let me go
open the journal
head back to your apartment I need to go
straight home
yo my New Yorkers man you know I only
been to New York one time
to me this looks a little bit like New
York man tell me I'm wrong am I wrong I
only been there one time
I can only give you an opinion from one
visit
I need to go straight home I love how
they just stopped me from going that way
how did she live that close
to the courthouse
she lives literally like right there
I wonder if this light's ever going to
change
is it going to be just green forever
hold up let's see
haha
oh
interesting it did turn
be smart
[Music]
it's not a very bad looking game the
textures and everything on the games
pretty on point
hello goodbye
oh [__]
right thought we wouldn't find you
hey uh
uh
Lisa
Lisa really I thought she was Lisa
that's Chrissy huh
hold on my defense you don't really look
like Elisa
oh where is it oh I don't have it all
right there were complications
not like I wanted to get caught stealing
the car but here we are
we don't like complications why is there
like no blood one would think you get
hit like that you're gonna bust your
nose or you're carrying that one a lot
today your lip
get like I could tell if she's hitting
her but it doesn't feel effective
it's not that easy it's been impounded
I'm not so special about this car anyway
it's none of your damn business
our boss Mr Gigan is very unhappy
so unless you get it back one of us is
gonna be in a lot of pain do I get to
pick
it's [__] alien I promise you
oh she shut up real fast there okay
find it just tell your boss instead of
chicken
all right
gig I just tell him I I need some more
time but but for now here's some
collateral
I thought home girls prepare the shooter
a second ago she just letting her get
away
man what did we start playing Assassin's
Creed
escape from the game
they won't even let me look back
[Music]
look man we're gonna get her we're gonna
get our gains right here
well we're demonetized I appreciate that
square units
they caught us
[Music]
okay okay let's actually run this time
they won't let me see you behind
are you okay
[__] I have to go I'm so sorry
I gotta find a way out of here
[Music]
it's how long it takes them to see me
over here
I'm right here
I'm waiting for you
I just played punch out last week I can
knock you guys out they came out of
nowhere
I gotta find a way out of here
[Music]
right yeah there's no point in running
you know
maybe it's safer to go through the alley
I love I love how he crouches
and then they were uh she gets just gets
up for no reason
see that's how you that's how you
parkour
you jumped off that dude
[Music]
almost there oh here we go here we go
here someone's gonna show up right here
where'd she go huh
little [__]
we will find you fright you will burn
[__] I feel like in a real life scenario
people aren't going to be screaming
in the middle of the street like that
because it's going to cause a lot of
attention
Palmer must be
way to get inside before I freeze
aren't these little fire hatches
supposed to be up a little bit though
foreign
she like in an abandoned building or
something
open the archives
review any useful information you've
acquired so a little thing about the
characters
there's the judge
oh so it's pretty much the judge used to
to get in a little bit of trouble she
wanted to give someone a
H come on man let's let's be fair we've
only started like 10-15 minutes of the
game
let's be fair
[Music]
it's a Holland Tunnel side of my folks
great disappearing act who leaves a
newborn baby on the street I went under
the it isn't that the I don't know at
least it was on the Queen's Midtown that
would have been an awful last name
I hear you man I hear you
all right she doesn't like this
that's all I have
I wonder where Homer's at
[Music]
my favorite kicks
man you could probably sell those those
shoes for some cat food I'm just gonna
point that out there you guys all day
[Music]
Alice in Wonderland I've been maybe able
to watch uh
that Netflix show Alice in Wonderland or
whatever it is
curiouser and curious
wish I could find that rabbit hole and
Tumble away to Wonderland
Allison borderline yeah that's the game
that's the show
I need to get into it right now I'm
watching
I need to get into Teen Titan uh Titans
I gotta watch something for r r by
tomorrow I'm about halfway through it so
I gotta finish that up probably tomorrow
I can start over
took long enough though
she got no cat food
but she got money
looking real sauce I ain't gonna lie
12 23
yeah I've seen last of us too the
episode two I'm sorry I'm late I know
you miss me
oh well thank you but my birthday isn't
for another few days oh I'll tell you
what I almost forgot
been so busy recently
oh well you know
important things to do
waiting for it slaying dragons
I'll let you in on a secret but I'm a
pretty big deal
real big deal
man I do feel bad for the main character
it's clearly about to have a mental
breakdown
we are getting out of this city Homer
away from the [__] the garbage the
cops I
it's just enough to get us started
[Music]
yeah
I promise we'll go somewhere that loves
cats
even ones like you
[Music]
bright Skies
been Breezy breaking into cribs jacking
whips all right she's trying to get away
sometimes you got to do some some off
the wall stuff man I don't I don't
co-sign it but you know people been
there
you get you get pushed
you get pushed too much
and you get down too much and you hit
rock bottom too much people will do some
some stuff man they'll do some stuff
[Music]
I do feel bad for
so far they've done a decent job
building her
her story
I don't think so far that the dialogue's
been horrible
[__]
Homer girl come on we gotta go
gotta find Homer first
gotta find Homer first I mean you could
just pick up the bag it's literally
right there I'm I'm just gonna be real
with you
and don't you love how like baby you're
just walking normal
how to it stops now you're not walking
normal but
Homer at least the cat's more to the
ground than anything
now
no no no no no
gotta get that money
[__] the bag yeah you should have
grabbed it
[Music]
is [__]
and finally The Blaze that engulfed the
abandoned building in the Hell's Kitchen
District of Manhattan has been ruled as
arson
luckily no one was harmed in the fire
the fdmy believe it was set by some
local gang members
the suspects are still at Large
if they found her and they call it the
place on fire why didn't they take the
money
I hope she's interested in Insurance
um I don't think she was living there
legally
sorry girl
amazing
Fray
what happened to you
you look like hell
are you allergic
what the cats are you allergic to cats
oh I love cats but
are you in trouble good
[Music]
she likes wet food the flaky kind
not pate
she needs a warm place to sleep
maybe I'll laugh every once in a while
and she needs a bath but good luck with
that pray what's going on her name is
Homer
promise me you'll look after her
promise
[Music]
what are you doing free
the right thing
I need some time to to sort some stuff
out but I'll come back for her it just
might take a while Fray wait if you're
in trouble I can help you free
happy holidays
all right
Homer's safe
I don't know what am I gonna do
I love how
[__]
oh my God
oh now we got a Spider-Man
full circle
you know would have been a better
happy birthday to me
a better
stamp a better storyline to me
is if she went to that other world got
abilities and she brought them back
imagine like
the intros the other way around where
you're in the fairy tale world and then
she is part of that world and she comes
back here and it's about her
understanding just because she has
powers that she doesn't need to
overthrow anyone
I'm streaming
what
88 person no wonder what that is
oh my God you can have a drink
not kind of like a Superman story I
think you could
you you could say it's a Superman story
but I think it's a little bit different
because I think she needs to come here
and you
like you're you're just
kind of having like
Superman kind of came with the mentality
I have power I need to be a better
person because of the power I have I'm
saying she comes in here from another
world and she and she's just messing
stuff up and she doesn't care and you
know through like human connections to
who she meets that is what eventually
leads to her you know becoming a good
person and you know maybe someone from
the actual other world could show up to
and that's like the main attack
huh
oh so that's okay nope not getting in
that way must be another way
definitely no one in here
seriously
that's what I'm saying like she's coming
in here she would come in here from
living in The Other Place her whole life
I mean wow
whoa
[Music]
achievement unlocked
yes we want to say the prayer yes
we want to save
so I guess now we're being transported
to the other place
and you know it would have been like a
cool little concept too those people
that attacked her
if she ended up
I don't know
jump back through
wait wait wait wait wait stop stop
come on
it's a good question I don't know yet
another dimension in the future I don't
know yet we're gonna find out though
as long as her abilities are used well
you know I don't really care about the
dialogue I care about the gameplay I'm
sure the dialogue's probably cringy in a
lot of places but we're about to find
out
where am I get out of your room yeah
we're definitely out of our room
what's happened to me
yeah that is a serious draft
you know what actually been okay let's
let's rewind the story again okay let's
do it again
so she comes here and it's a Time skip
and it's like 10 15 years and at the end
of the time skip
she she like rules the world she rules
this Dimension and then she ends up
going back New York and losing all of
her powers and people from this wrong
come with her and it's about her
rebuilding herself back up yeah and you
know confronting the people that she she
ran into it'd be it'd be lit obviously
you know it's probably easier to make
these kind of terrains than it is to do
something like that in the city no
yes no yes
you the one talking to me right now or
this
cuff
cuff it's a bit reductive isn't it cough
maybe vampires oh fan price
yeah no it's definitely no no this is
batshit bananas and yet it's the truth
you stop you're hurting me
oh
seriously no
but what you're doing is completely
futile
how is this happening well what were you
doing before this was happening
I was
[Music]
doesn't matter it doesn't matter
all right chapter two
stock still here
whoever is doing this stop this is one
sick joke I am out of here
can't run away from me
I am literally attached to you
why don't we settle down a bit and talk
about ourselves I don't like the accent
for the Godless
get this morning workout
let's get this morning workout man
we're gonna we we're going for the
Olympics when we get back
that's how she's gonna she's gonna stop
being homeless
she's about to go for the Olympics we
got to get her in Tip-Top shape
I just don't
what is how do I
do I jump
no
I mean she was jumping those fences why
can't she jump now
all right let's go this way
be careful not to trip on anything
you can also see things this cannot be
[__] real
I don't like to me Fray how the hell do
you know my name we are bonded bonded
what do you mean bonded
why is this happening
this is no the on Bond on bond now
as you can see you're stuck with me and
I with you and only you can hear me
stop stop talking this is completely
insane
pray slow down you need to listen to me
no what I need is to figure out how to
get better
what
hide
oh a dragon
how do they just go from screaming
and the dragon didn't hear them
is it gone yes and we should leave this
place as well
not there
I'm sure the creature is far away by now
and besides what you won't last long
without anything to eat
fine and how exactly do you plan on
getting out
I believe
climbing that wall might be our best
option
what are we going to get into the
into the melee portion
[Music]
hey cuff
we ain't talking to him
[Music]
all right let's go
whoa what the [__] was that oh one of my
talents
it seems like
foreign
[Music]
what are you the extent of my abilities
uh-huh
so this is Athea Janu
Janu I thought you said I see a big
picture Junoon small picture Janu is
part of Matthew
I get it like New York City versus New
York State
exactly
think
I have no idea
no not in Newark New York is there a
difference about a million
[Music]
her mom will be getting home here soon
look at you I'd be careful
come on don't be shy seriously I
wouldn't let's just keep moving why are
you so freaked out by this fella
you tell me that now [__]
well don't just stand there what's up
Gene Park man
hold up Gene we about to the attack
Magic
what the
stop panicking now
oh Panic this thing is small fried
man cuff was tripping got all this
ability he's sitting there let's move on
man we should have fought that Dragon I
did not just do that we did
I just move [__] with my mind perhaps
our connection has somehow awoken some
abilities I just moved [__] with my mind
I just keep hearing III I just move [__]
with my freaking mind
yeah okay that is something I do know I
do magic talk to sentient cuffs kill
jacked up Beats say okay hold up hold up
now you're just being ridiculous oh
that's
oh
I actually don't mind the way she
speaking because there are there are
people let me move this up a little bit
there is people that speak like that
I think it's the cuff that's making no
sense because look at your perspective
you are someone that came from another
realm with no magic you can't do
something like that
it would make more sense that she would
react in that way now obviously the
dialogue could have been a little bit
better you know
but
the cuff is the one
that makes no sense because he's
supposed to be grounded
he's supposed to be the one that's from
this this region so she was talking the
way she's doing and the cuff would have
been more grounded in his conversation
more prep like more like mind-centric
instead of like like a like a real
cringy because he's he's encouraging her
her dialogue and I feel like that's the
issue the issue is the cuff isn't
grounding her he's encouraging her
dialogue
can you fix the TV you find me the
controller
it's right there
what do you want to watch
Elsa and Anna
the cuff actually makes sense later blew
my mind okay
you know as long as the cuff actually
makes sense
oh it came stop it
is that what you wanted
it's too far good to know there's a line
if you could just Master these new
abilities with my help of course um did
you not just see me take out that gnarly
Beast
oh bring it you mangle monsters
so far it's
I will say that it's it's cringy at some
point so far but I wouldn't say people
are acting like the dialogue is a lot
lot worse and I haven't got really far
in the game so
animals here they did seem somewhat
altered didn't they
such a mutation yeah like what happened
here
that's it
I do think she's picking up on these
abilities too much
foreign
[Music]
she is picking upon these abilities a
little bit too much well
well malignant miasma in the air okay
turning back now it doesn't seem to be
affecting you though does it
besides I doubt there'd be much benefit
in retracing your steps
so this miasma what exactly is it it's
quite mysterious isn't it
I suspect it might be what's causing all
the local Wildlife to look so peculiar
so how come I can't get down on the
voice of the cuff man
choice of traveling companion Birds
no not that definitely not that
nothing but ruins
looks like no one's been here for a
while I wonder how long everything's
been in it perhaps we should fight I'm
not going to decrease it Jane because
I feel like
the actual something that devs wanted
you to play it this way because it's all
by default
there's life forms here
oh no
support Magic
L2 L1
that went well
you bet it did that [__] is going
nowhere
I like the the magic system in the game
it kind of weird that like
you don't really see where she's getting
the source of power from
it'd be cool if it showed it like like
use the ground beneath you but it
doesn't really do that it just randomly
shows out of nowhere
so much for clean air and bright Skies
try to escape oh what is this where do I
wind up someplace ten times worse oh
poor you
man if she went back to the real world
to do all kinds of nonsense with this
you don't have to worry about the three
strike rule who's gonna put you in jail
come back
foreign
okay it's a little bit stronger than I
anticipated
I'm gonna keep shooting it though
foreign
I just got turned around all right all
right that was weird like I'm fighting
someone obviously
surge Magic
moving on up
what are you trying to hit ah
ow
ing blows
let's get him
[Music]
oh no animation for the killing blows
Gene
be real with me man did that disappoint
you no animation for killing blows maybe
God of War is just ruined that aspect
for me where I expect everything that I
come up to someone it's it's an
animation for killing blows
foreign
[Music]
not bad
thanks I told you to call me van brace
sure cuff sure
[Music]
I'd be wiser to run this no I think we
could fight them no kidding
[Music]
foreign
yeah yeah yeah
what
yeah
what you guys doing
come on
hold up Kim
I got your back
foreign
I could run like the wind and I'm not
even getting tired
that was close
where the hell are we now
a big city I suppose
hello I don't like how the the cuff
trying to act like you don't know what's
going on
well let's keep looking
you should probably keep an eye out for
somewhere to rest too
let's see what's over there
this looks like a world that you would
have in um
in like Dark Souls guys
it kind of much seems that way
this oldness with the air and drove him
to escape to save the classes I hope so
at least that would mean they're still
alive
[Music]
oh here we go I like the the parkouring
the comet in the parkouring is pretty
nice so far
[Music]
well this place is fun
I imagine it was once happy smiling
faces on every corner no I could picture
it now
damn everything just looks broken
not exactly the most poetic of
descriptions but yes I suppose it does
is there nowhere that's not like broken
by this [__] I suppose there might be
somewhere
the four realms
so they got they built a little bit of
lore in this game
[Music]
I love how like you just randomly find
this house with electricity
to some degree it looks like there's
some form of maybe
um
I don't know because there's no candles
lit up there but it seems like there's
like maybe a candle light or electricity
to some degree in a bed
and you just find it
sounds like trouble
yes and given what we've seen so far I'd
say you need to be very careful in case
you're planning on investigating
how's everything blue
[__] what is it now
is this the brake shit's doing too I
believe so it's
cost everything it touches before
destroying it completely
oh
foreign
you know we we welcome you to the
influencer space Gene it's got to start
making some videos got to start being
proactive with the video making Gene
you could multitask Gene you could do
both
oh
foreign
[Music]
yeah it's the big red thing in the
middle
[Music]
all right it's all right as it can be
foreign
[Music]
I love the combat I'm not gonna lie it's
very flashy
oh did you see that if I didn't see my
hard work paying dividends
that's it show that Beast what it means
to
think is it probably not you might want
to find some cover
fast uh now I'm not trying to teach any
of the influencer way I'm just trying to
help people if they need anything I I'm
a horrible influencer in general man
there's people doing what I do 10 times
better
[Music]
unblockable attack
oh okay so you can't dog those
even doing anything I think so keep
chipping away
I don't know
yeah
that's the stuff yes I'm gonna need more
cover and quickly
scratched
has anyone ever told you
hey [__] off
come on drop dead already I'm afraid
I'll reptilian friend seems as
stubbornly healthy as ever
hairy
[__]
what did I do to Desert this
oh
[Music]
my God
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
I do feel like you fought the dragon too
soon
do you think it's dead the Dragon no
well it did get crushed by all that
Rubble
it's definitely not dead
I do think that this system is a little
clunky
it doesn't feel like I'm an entirely
like 100 control over what's going on
now obviously it's the beginning so
that's probably gonna change
but I wish I felt more control
it feels pretty consistent
what how does that thing I even have
scratch
foreign
[Music]
getting on now
you weren't supposed to win that fight
foreign
[Music]
but you'll die if you fall from up here
I'm gonna die anyway [__]
[Music]
this is exciting
are you all right
I think so
all right
looks like there's a town out there
hopefully one that isn't deserted well
you'll never find out if you don't go
and see
dialogue like that from the bracelet it
just is unnecessary oh hey
huh
the hell
move monster hey
you falling monster the monster speaks
yeah of course I speak and put your
pointy stick away [__] move all right
move it
where are we now this is the city of
support
why are they speaking English
it's my experience that languages share
commonalities across many dimensions
okay any answer works for me I guess
what
see that could have just said that the
the bracelet translated their language
like what they should have done is they
should have started with a different
language and the bracelet was like hold
on hold up let me let me handle it and
it starts translating
who are you child who are you I would
humble thyself and answer their
questions I got this I'm used to repping
myself I don't think you comprehend the
gravity of your situation I gotten
myself on a much tougher scrape than
this thank you very much the one you
shut your shiny mouth and let me do the
talking
it looks like she's talking to herself
with demons what no and and who uses
Cahoots I would like to hear the answer
to councilman's question child
my name is Frey Holland I do not know
how I got here I am exhausted I am
starving and all I want is to go home
harvestments are strange where is she
from a Hell's Kitchen you see she is
Hell spawn how else could she survive in
the corruption
[Music]
how did you emerge from the corruption
of genuine unscathed I wouldn't exactly
say on skates it's because she and the
corruption are one and the same we must
execute her immediately wait what no
that's that's crazy I don't even know
how I got here please listen to me
I believe we need her
who wishes to address the council
forgive me I am odd and Keen
all this woman is guilty of is surviving
the corrupted lands we have much to
learn from her
until now we've only met her with blades
perhaps we could extend her a hand of
kindness the devil will accept you
as it bites your hands spreading its
venomous corruption into your
s
[Music]
the councilwoman palette please yeah
both all in King councilman Genesis have
made very compelling arguments
council is divided do you guys think the
the soundtrack there'll be no blood
spilled today is going along with what's
happening listen to the soundtrack and
listen to the situation that's going on
they don't really
match too much take her to the Tower of
Pinoy please councilman Belen your
ruling is too harsh council is adjourned
she has done nothing wrong with a
tarapanoi what's the Tower of annoy I
believe it's a prison please what oh
hell no I'm not getting locked up again
let me go let me go don't touch me
[__]
phrase Journey
completed
plus I think they should have built up
those individuals more
I felt like you just getting thrown
straight into that scenario
and I just thought it felt no okay chat
well let me set up real quick
I personally feel like getting in front
of that court and Stuff felt a little
too forced like if you think about it
the pacey's just off it feels fast and
pacing like you go from learning how to
use the bracelet
to not only mastering multiple moves
because let's keep in mind
she shot one thing at the beginning and
it's like she knew how to use all three
of the abilities just from using one of
them then she fights a couple more big
things then she learns how to like Glide
then she's into a battle a Dragon Battle
it's just and now we're in a courtroom
in a matter of like 20 30 minutes
I feel like there's no build up
get up
get up get up get up look
I am imprisoned a million miles from
home in a renfair nightmare just let me
die in peace if you die I'm just a
meaningless bauble that they bury you
with and I am fine with that
just leave me alone
you know what
you're not of this is my fault this is
all your functions how exactly this is
my fault
can we just not talk fine
by me see yourself I have a bit of
Silence fantastic
what's going on
you say another [__] word
I feel like they try to make
comedy and if it feels forced
you know I never thought I'd miss the
Hell's Kitchen Courthouse
I love how she's not trying to use
a bracelet to get out of this of course
it's locked
I doubt he'll be squeezing your way to
Freedom through there
no [__]
damn it this is going nowhere
Alex um
dude that piss bucket wants something to
annoy once the the you know what the
stream's over then I'll go into how I
feel about it New York how hard is that
to remember maybe it's hard to remember
as van brace
if memory serves me right you weren't
exactly in the best of spirits when our
paths first crossed
I'm not sure why you're so determined to
return
you know what I'm just gonna use magic
to bust us out of here it isn't
advisable to use your abilities in front
of them why not you already think I'm In
Cahoots with demons but they will hang
you for being a heretic what like a
Salem situation
do you expect me to know what that means
look we did it your way and now we're
gonna try it my way
foreign
did I just do that quick put this on
who's there
I will free you would you have to put it
on and do as I say
put it on
okay it's on
you
you're the one who stood up for me in
court
why are you doing this
because I believe you
but we must hurry I believe how did you
sneak past the guards
I prepared a tincture of Slumber baked
into a pastry hmm looks can really be
deceiving let's go before they wake wait
where are we going what's your angle
angle should it defend you in court and
right now she seems to be your only
option Fair Point all right wherever
we're going there's got to be food well
this is serendipitous you're telling me
did you say something what uh no please
and this chick needs to stop arguing
with the person that freed them when's
the last time you saw a movie or a TV a
movie TV show video game where someone
is someone freeze you from your captive
and you argue with them about their
intentions and how they got there you
don't see that often so it's kind of
it's kind of weird it's happening here
you sure this is a good idea I mean
aren't you gonna get yourself in trouble
don't worry about me besides I couldn't
just stand idly by or they treated you
so unfairly
I was just checking on you who were
those people running the trial you mean
the Council of support
they're the leaders of our city they
settle all our disputes
judge Ann jury all rolled into one huh
efficient
foreign man they really put them in the
tallest tower you could think of
tallest tower known to man as you can
see our land suffers
everything that corruption touches it
breaks
yeah
I saw it up close
it's real [__] up in there
demonetized not pleasant indeed Athea is
all but lost
where did the break [__] come from
I'll tell you soon enough we must keep
moving
[Music]
so where are we going exactly
we should make our way to the lower City
the lower City got it
they got some really
generic names lower City
I don't know ain't it man what were you
even doing at the courtroom no one has
arrived from outside the city for many
years everyone in town wants to know who
you are
the price of notoriety I guess
after what you called the break [__]
let's just go with the break after the
break occurred
people fled their villages
the Paul is the last Bastion damn
I don't feel like the music's necessary
here walking down these stairs
I would advise staying off the main
thoroughfares
less chance of being spotted
no we should stay off the main
thoroughfares
less chance of being spotted
you're right
wow nice digs some schmancy houses this
is where the nobility live hi look
you're talking literally right next to
him
[Music]
how is this dude not hearing you talk
literally right behind him
find out she can't have got far
they walked right by her oh my God these
guards man it appears they've
[Music]
why can't you be more like her she likes
all my ideas
[Music]
I don't know why the chick
they homeboys like if they find out
you're a heretic they're good they'll
execute you
why does it even matter I'ma just kill
them
[Music]
it doesn't look like these people have
magical abilities why does it matter if
they know I'm a heretic or not
I love they put the he put the she put
the cloak on so people wouldn't see her
head but she still has like modern
clothes on so wouldn't that defeat the
point
of putting the cloak on just because
they can't see your head don't mean they
don't see the the clothes that just
stand out in this time error in this
kind of like universe
a lot of a lot of gaps in this story man
a lot of gaps in the store
[Music]
you are safe now uh thanks we are close
to where I live come I have food
guys
she got food we bout to eat
a bit of a half-hearted thank you I must
say
nobody does anything nice without
wanting something in return I have trust
issues
do you trust me
well you and I have as an Unholy
Alliance at best I couldn't get rid of
you even if I wanted to
she did just risk her own life to get
you out of jail
point taken you know I've been watching
the stream and I've been thinking about
what I would stream how would you guys
feel if I like streamed the whole Zelda
franchise more interested in the food at
the moment the entire Zelda franchise I
would maybe not like I'll probably start
with the 3D stuff because I don't really
want to play like the older stuff I know
that might sound bad but you know I'll
probably start with like Ocarina of Time
because I gotta start with games that's
easy for me to get a hold of
we can speak freely here
I am odd and Keen
daughter of robian and probably start
Ocarina of Time than the Majora's Mask
great Holland
daughter of who the f knows
I don't know how to respond
[Music]
it's okay boring story I'm over it liar
oh that was horrible
yeah my father wasn't notable cognition
cognizant cognizant you say tomato I say
tomato tomato
you are very strange Frey cognitions are
athea's most highly respected Scholars
and my mother was a general
that is a lot to live up to wait was
I've been on my own almost my whole life
I know what that's like I don't have any
parents I had some Foster ones but they
never really said I'm going to put a
pole feel the same way that we got
royally screwed that we must help others
tomato tomato
uh this the the cringe man
this is my home
you live in a bar above
I like you more and more
so about that food
you had this on you the whole time I
needed you to follow me for a Holland's
daughter of who the f knows
just phrase fine and not well played
well thanks for the jailbreak lady and
the Apple but uh this is where he part
ways
please wait
I need your help to save my homework
please wait mystery solved that's not
happening
the circle of bending light the rushing
sound
that's what brought you here yes
you want to go back home don't you
I may be able to help you
[Music]
I'll give you to the bottom of a drink
I love how they're not acting like this
woman doesn't have a bracelet with
superhuman powers
hey
sorry I didn't see you give it back
one
she took her phone pickpocketing never
give back what you stole
the first rule don't get caught
what is it Anyway
something like with crap here see when
she picked pocket her she had to touch
her physically touch her she felt her
grab it but if you physically bump into
them
it would have worked a lot better
it would have been harder for her to to
uh
fight uh for her to the point of your
finest build the lift
Kim stop it
get your feet oh it was hell of a kick
you guys do not mess around
all right let's hear it this isn't gonna
last long
come on get out my father researched the
phenomenon known as the Tarana
extensively Toronto
the tunnel of light you travel through
I believe his work holds the answer's
unique the people behind the studio is
Zelda honest
it's the people who made Final Fantasy
15. find his research notes on the break
they are in the break right
it does not seem to have any effect on
you so they say
many have tried to find what's outside
the city but they don't get far before
what
you are the only hope we have
salt me Obi-Wan Kenobi you're my only
hope okay you obviously don't know me
[Music]
I want proof
follow me and I'll show you and
cute I haven't said yes
do you believe her
okay this thing is possible
some chance is better than their chance
I do not want to go back into that
hellscape come on we'll be fine
I'll be with you I'll fly
I know I'm wanted but I'll walk up and
talk to you
[Music]
the bracelets talking to her
is this then here folks
yes it was painted when we were at one
of the cognition's guilds
father was one of the cognitions I'm
asking you guys about the twitch thing
because when I start streaming it's
going to be on Twitter noon fell to the
break
got to figure out how many of you guys
are willing to come on over there yes
he brought me here to keep me safe from
break right she's at work right now here
in about 20 minutes before we went back
to finish his work
that was 20 years ago I can't right now
she's at work I saw him again
and the break eventually overtook
everything outside the city
oh what's up Smitty Smith I appreciate
you coming through
[Music]
I kind of want to get back to the combat
could you tell me about him he was a
brilliant man beloved by many
he was close to finding a way of slowing
down the break maybe even reversing it
people put their faith in him believed
that he would make the world how it used
to be
I'm trying my hardest to continue his
work to keep hope alive
here these are his notes on the Tirana
yeah yeah this looks familiar you can
have this after you help me
quid pro quo I get it he kept his notes
on the break in read journals like this
one I need you to find them and bring
them back
okay so I go and get the journals bring
them back and then we're Square that's
the full extent of my savior
I will do everything in my power to help
you get home you have my word
Cross Your Heart and Hope today
you wish me dead oh my God no no it's a
phrase we have on our forget it
I shall pretend those words were never
uttered good
okay I'm in why not it's not like I've
got any better options
it's good news it's good news guys it's
good news uh not why I'm doing it but
yeah sure if you're planning on heading
into the break you'll need to get some
rest
I'll go in the morning you got anywhere
I can crash
crash
I gotta sleep oh of course
follow me
because I said so
you can use this room whenever you like
and I'll prepare a change of clothes for
you thanks
you're a lifesaver
impaling stuff we're about to sleep too
man
what a [__] day
still can't tell if any of this is real
and yet it is
um now rest
you have another big day tomorrow
[Music]
yeah it doesn't seem like she
she's very conscious of pretty much
anything
yeah we'll save
oh so this is where she gets the fit
from
I do like the the outfit she has on
[Music]
hooded cloak
now you look
one of us I'm skipping that dialogue
we already know what she wants
she wants to go to certain part
and that's what we're doing
find these journals
we skipping that too
so how do we get to this cognizant's
Guild place if I'm reading the peasant
girls math correctly we'll need to leave
the city by the south gate
oh my God
chat what's going on
[Music]
yo that was a maiden that was crazy
oh gosh
damn it I mean
well that was a short trip
how the hell do you get out of this dump
anyway
I know away
that's that chick that tried to steal
the phone
not really
and you'll pray everyone's been talking
about you
I guess I'm kind of famous around here
so everyone's been talking about you
and the guards can't find you
does that make sense to you guys I call
it find his keeper
damn
did you steal all this stuff
no all of it
you're growing
you got me kid
yeah you know
I'll pick up uh Dead Space
at a different time
they got a crafting system in here
[Music]
you guys are stupid man I really do
throw a lot of stuff
way huh yes a lot of useless rubbish
wait this might come in handy
you found some crafting materials use
them to improve your cloak on the
crafting bench
oh my God
I get it
[Music]
hey shorty I got you something
that thingy said is it worth crap no not
my cell phone and thanks for not swiping
that again
I don't steal from Friends
cool
well as your friend I got you this
wow what is that are you a taunter
pen light and no I'm not a taunter
what's the deal with those guys anyway
they were the strongest and most
powerful woman in athia they all had
gifts in the past they use them to help
protect the land but one day they will
again
they'll come and save us
listen kid from personal experience you
gotta look out for yourself
people only really get saved in fairy
tales
you're wrong
you'll see oh now we're skipping it
do that just giving it again no okay
let's give
[Music]
here we go
still can't
do though
the fast travel stuff
yes let's leave
let's go
yeah I agree they're trying they're
trying too hard to prove that she's the
the chosen one
why don't you trust issues
because I've been there all right
what the hell are these things are they
people
I believe this is what happens when
humans are affected by the break
and I can't kill them
Which choice do you have
you have
some morale so this is where all the
amendments are saying people who come
out here don't make it very far
explains why the people who support the
first game
I hear you man you're so [__] clingy
and coming
look at that trying to hit me you
couldn't couldn't touch me
[Music]
oh
do you think you might consider getting
hit a little less
why do you think I am super human I wish
I had like a melee attack
[Music]
oh
let me guess mentally at least you know
me so well
you guys can't do nothing
[Music]
look at that
oh
ah
yeah
battle ranking
reasonably impressive I suppose
reasonably
some kind of tree with something
the front's a blessing
[Music]
whoa you feel that
some people gave this an eight out of
eight and nines out of ten
is this like the place that she can hide
foreign
leap
kick off from a wall in order to climb
higher
all right
so they're teaching you how to use these
abilities
hygiene gave it a six unbiased lies what
the hell was that did something happen
I don't know
feel more powerful I think
some kind of Cathedral oh Refugee that
was refugee
Pilgrim refugee
pilgrims refugee
oh so these are fast travel vacations
she was greeted by the most miraculous
site oh and there's a crafting somewhere
to light the [__] down
all right let's move I see what people
are talking about
how she cusses too much
come on guys
oh
we got this
yeah
oh come on
all right
whoa I really don't like how I don't
have a melee I'd probably get that but I
think I I like when you have melees at
the beginning of the game
especially I feel like that's making
this game not as fluid as could be is
right just the lack of a melee
[Music]
put that down cam
zombies they're everywhere air I'm sure
they were nice people before but come on
all right good night
I do like the uh the combat in this game
I wish the uh the movement was a little
bit more
because it just like I didn't want to go
up there I felt like the game just put
me up there I just don't think it's
consistent
ready for this
you can't stop it leave it drop it
got you on your toes now
you're mine
you can melee people too easy
let's do the little finisher
look at that
manifolds
look out
right in The Sweet Spot
oh yeah
thank you
oh
damn
I think that's all of them there we go
seems like it nice work
oh that gotta hurt
gotcha
get you guys
his money
yes and money is uh completely useless
I don't like the the coffee man
I honestly don't I I'm not annoyed by
the main character I'm annoyed by that
damn bracelet
that's it
all right
what still running off
closer spray
[Music]
you look dropped at cam
look
probably at the tournament of my head
according to the map it is yes
probably to turn my camera off
I just
like yeah
you're not joking aren't you
my uh my
my camera's been overheating here
recently
I don't know what that's about
come on
[Music]
put yourself together no no wow
she kind of played me there what the
thing kind of played me Kim get in here
thank you
girlfriend's all for it she's probably
on her way home
so I probably got another like
10 minutes I can stream plus my head's
my control uh
the camera's saying that it's it's hot
again
I don't know what's up with that
kind of magic requires more range I kind
of guessed that already
[__]
ing
[Music]
hey yeah
you don't hang around do you
have no point wasting time
staying here
think fast
what is this
momentums
[Music]
okay so this doesn't look good breaking
this I can grow my stream
but I expect you can clear it away with
your panels give it a try why I'm
shooting man
there we go
press that one I want to switch to melee
combat
[Music]
just breathe will you you'll never hit
anything otherwise
not helping
one second
according to them after I beat this dude
that's not doing much
I don't like the look of this
why does they hit me regardless what I
do
yeah okay
try this for size whoa
come on
it's not a deer kid
oh it's not
that looks like a deer to you
dad
this
you're ridiculous well this doesn't look
good yes something seems to have drawn
the break here
but I expect you can clear it away with
your parents give it a try
that's it
here it comes
and more of Phoenix Rising was what was
was good I actually really enjoyed that
game
what
you're hungry you just ate
hold up no get go come back in here I'll
be there in one second
wait I will get you something to snack
on in one second
this looks like a big one
oh my God man this is bitters
yes where's the taste the better it
works right
put yourself together no I'm not
all right guys
I think we're it's a wrap
yeah let's
let's switch to the
to the intermission screen
I don't want
I have a
watching the girlfriend's daughter don't
want her in the Stream
ah all right
so I played about two hours I played
about two hours of forsaka
for spoken
I actually think that the issue with the
game isn't the main character it's the
bracelet the bracelet just
I don't know maybe you you have to play
more to understand the bracelet but I
just feel like the bracelet is more out
of character than she is
like she feels like she's cringy
to a degree
she's cringy because she's from another
realm and you know as crazy as that
might be to us there are people that act
like that in the real world
you know that maybe they could have did
the writing a little bit better
but I feel like he's the the biggest
cringy portion of it because he
shouldn't be that cringy
he should be more you know real
realistic about everything
you know I do feel like the story has a
lot of holes in it already and I haven't
even played that much of it
but
I think it could do something
uh
what Alpha what I played I wouldn't
recommend it for 70 bucks especially
probably pick it up for like 20 30.
so far
you know I think the mailing is pretty
good A clunky a little clunky clunky
to a degree
but I think it does what it would have
meant out to do I do think it does what
it was meant out to do
it's just that the movement I feel is so
clunky
that when you're trying to do something
sometimes it doesn't make it feel like
it's supposed to do it
yeah I I do feel like the actual
development team that did this could do
something good with their their
franchise they just gotta really go in
for it you know
it is we'll see what happens you know
there's a lot of scenarios that goes
into stuff like this
but you know I don't here's the thing
I feel like
they could have easily have made like
she's too understanding and being in a
world with dragons and stuff I feel like
there was that little bit at the
beginning she was confused where she was
but she ended up getting right through
that staying at people's house she
didn't know like she's in a world that
she shouldn't be this comfortable in and
I think that's the biggest issue
she brings this
what's what I'm looking for this cringe
this personality with her from the other
place but she acts like it doesn't exist
and I think
and all that's the issue I think that's
the issue and all
but
that's my early Impressions uh you know
I'm playing another game right now so
even if I wanted to get to reviewing
this I won't I don't know if I can get
to reviewing this I might strain this
more on Twitch
uh it just depends on what happens right
now I am reviewing
Fire Emblem and
fire was a way better game uh from what
I played a fire and if I want to play
this so I'm going to continue playing
fire but I appreciate it for coming
through man we had a total of like 120
people in here you guys showed up
exactly how I knew you guys would show
up you know I I'm gonna really sit down
talk to some people I know on Twitch and
we're gonna get this popping we're gonna
get this twitch thing going you know I
I feel more comfortable doing the
streaming thing I really do I feel a lot
more comfortable doing the streaming
thing
um but you know I want to I want the how
I would like to run the streams you know
we got games that we play together
we got games that I play other
influencers and then I got games that I
play by myself that we just crack jokes
and chill that's all I want to get
things done but we'll figure that out in
in the meantime man we'll figure that
out but I'm pretty sure for coming
through and until next time this is
gaming addict Lord addict